welcome to this video playing he's so
calm 44 from China yeah okay you never
know maybe there's some exotic flag
that's just very similar to China
because of the small footprint of this
flag okay let's see we have a um check
on something that is quite similar to
them to the Cambridge Springs only with
the night on d 2 and this is a
difference really Wow and I saw that one
okay so maybe he's trying to take yeah
well see five does not look too great
yeah I don't really if he takes I don't
really want to take with the bishop and
give this visual of strange especially
not if I must give up a tempo and take
with the Queen at the end of all of that
hmm don't know what to do
John capitals don't see I don't see
something else brilliant I didn't want
to do that Knight takes Queen tags but
just didn't didn't see anything anything
better okay at least he's not playing b6
and tending Bishop a six okay maybe I
could have taken actually like Evan so
this sir should be should be okay for me
let's see he's going for this cookie
five takes Knight be three years going
back to c7 analysis he will also do that
oh wait maybe I can and maybe I can do
that now be five
maybe this is good enough for small
advantage at least I take here Jake's I
can take on g7 okay so um Queen 10
Quincy five will take here so do i need
to take what the Queen may be okay so we
have a position where I best i have the
miniscule advantage but i have lost two
minutes and okay if he takes take with
the night i really like that 27s are
strange one
and anyway I need to be be quick about
it
now I've got slightly the more active
pieces but I don't really know if it
should amount to much yeah maybe when I
outside was a bleak back rank and I make
sure that I'm not mated null 95 was
another possibility
we have 96 this is important or night f5
what's better not sure and they don't
really have time to figure it out check
Rukia III takes a two nuts that's too
slow time warning check
I need to go to c3 somehow f43 a bee
farm also would be a route now we can
try Knight to c3 and this would be good
but I take a tune you cannot go nite a
farm vigoss night d five nights III my
95 is good I don't really see a reply
I don't see a reply Knight c3 rookie
move rookie one and let's go it's gone
here I this one there is you better to
lose that really Adair the econ was too
strong there was some thinking I can
take the pawn it down stop it but it's
not not on white resides yeah Jeff I
really cannot play 96 this is already
losing its already losing yeah of course
I need to improve before because why the
serve is just more comfortable but it's
it's a matter of really precise play
maybe maybe ins like h4s already lots of
a tempo chan now that's tricky really
tricky to play here a second coming
challenge so let's and need to really
switch that off so what's the way to the
computer gives this as check leading two
to the advantage that there should be
something I mean not like I'm winning
but I should maintain something simply
because of the better piece activity
Bishop here is probably forced and
then this is the best line yeah
something like that check very very long
line leading to a good position for
white here is not so quick with the a
porn he's ahead of the corner not behind
it it's a big difference and here yeah
yeah this this seems silly to draw check
no but ok I well that's completely
unrealistic to I don't even understand
why yeah I'm quick enough year old 1a to
keeney to now I'm not even sure that
this is a wrong minutes Chucky still
yeah it very our three that's not really
now really a bit disappointed about all
this I mean black is just them being
very passive from the get-go and I
played exactly in a way that I can win
it is a really really bad play a plate
96 is this any better really it's still
the same yeah I can I don't have the
time to take this it's really a terrible
misjudgment essentially I'm losing too
much time if I right now get the pieces
back I might be able to stop the porn
but all this was just just bad yeah but
I still couldn't really tell
the computer is also suggesting that age
4 is not good i mean this is a typically
human move it wants to play that and now
night be three maybe intending this
smooth now while a computer engine is is
terribly good at this type of position
where it is pure calculation there's
nothing to judge here or any strategical
whatever you just need to calculate like
a machine and get to the best possible
position and yeah this also maintains
something for white but I simply played
badly alright thanks for watching